♪ Money, money, money
♪ Over hoes, hoes, hoes
♪ We just want that
money, that money
- Fuck boys?
We are not fuck boys Colonel.
- Yeah we aren't
fuck boys at all.
Wait what's a fuck boy Vinny?
- Well, well, well.
If it isn't my piece of shit
son talking about fucking boys.
- Fuck you Mom!
- And his handsome friend Vinny.
- Hey Mrs. Peppersnacks,
how are you?
- Moist.
And not just 'cause I'm
packed in water honey
'Cause I'm horny for dick.
- Mom!
♪ That's Vinny & The Colonel
- I've been thinking about
that fuck boy comment Vinny.
- Just let it go Colonel,
there's nothing we can do.
- Well I did some
creepy internet stuff
and found out where
Timmypop goes to school.
- Really?
- Yeah I also found out
his sister has lupus.
- Uhh, okay, I don't
see how that's relevant.
- It might come up Vinny.
- I highly doubt that.
- Hey Timmypop, I heard
your sister has lupus
- Who the fuck are you guys?
- You called us fuck
boys on the internet.
- Move aside Vinny, I'm
about to stab a child.
- Hey, what's going on here?
♪ Money, money, money
♪ Over hoes, hoes, hoes
♪ We just want that
money, that money
- You're some of the biggest
fuck boys I've ever seen.
Have you considered F.B.B.C.?
- Vinny, I think this guy
wants us to watch porn.
- No, Fuck Boy
Behavioral Center.
It's a place where fuck
boys like you can go
and learn how to, well,
how to un-fuck yourselves.
Here, take some literature.
- (Vinny) A rehab center
for recovering fuck boys?
Seems sketchy and made up.
(hip-hop beat)
(Thunder)
- Hello boys, I'm Dr.
D'Angelo, head of the F.B.B.C.
I founded this center
in honor of my late wife
and I've been helping cure
fuck boys like you ever since
- We are not fuck boys dude.
- Well if you're so sure
that you aren't fuck boys
just step on the scale.
(scale honks)
- Oh that proves it
Vinny, we're fuck boys!
- I'm going to
recommend our intensive
fuck boy rehab program.
- And you think that'll cure us?
- It's a risky operation,
but it's a risk I'm
willing to take.
Now let's move along, so
much fuckery so little time.
(hip-hop beat)
Next I'm going to ask you
fuckwads a few questions.
Try to answer them honestly.
- Uh, what are all
these wires for?
- This machine
gages your answers
and fucks you in the ass
should you fucking answer
like a fuck boy you fucks.
- Wait, seriously?
- No not really,
it just shocks you
should you answer
like a fuck boy.
Now, first question:
A girl gives you her
number, what do you do?
- Dick pictures.
(buzz)
- Hmm, not surprising.
Dicktures are the
lifeblood of the fuck boy.
Now moving on to question two:
Your boy asks you
if you would like
to throw down upon some cocaine.
What do you say?
- Tell him I
probably won't do any
and then ask for tiny
key bumps all night
until the coke's gone.
(buzz)
- Holy shit, the fuck
boy is strong in you two.
Now finally, what do you
think of this fashion?
(buzz)
- Disgusting
- Psst, hey Colonel.
There's something seriously
fucked up going on here.
We should go check it out.
- The pills are working Vinny.
I can feel the fuck boy,
it's leaving my body.
(farts)
- Ugh no dude, you're
literally pooping on the floor.
- (Colonel) uugh
- Damn those pills that you
took earlier from that nurse
that I also took,
but I spit them out
because I'm skeptical
of all of this shit.
(scale honks)
- Interesting.
(hip hop beat)
(buzz)
- This machine
doesn't gage answers,
that bastard doctor just
shocks whoever he wants
to make them think
they're fuck boys
(fart)
- Ketamine, dammit I knew it.
(record scratch)
- Colonel you gotta wake up,
I was right this
whole place is a scam.
Fuck boys aren't
even a real thing.
- Oh yes they are,
and you're the biggest
fuck boy of them all Vinny.
- Why are you doing this?
- Because a fuck
boy stole my wife
- I thought your wife was dead?
- Well she's fucking dead to me.
When I went away
to medical school
it was hard for my wife
and I to communicate.
So I suggested we get snap chat.
(laughs)
- Snap chat?
No one communicates
on Snap Chat dude.
They just send
pictures of their like
pussies and dicks
and tits and shit.
- If only I had
known that back then.
It only took a day
before my wife's phone
was flooded with cock.
She left me and ever since,
I've dedicated my life
to ridding the world
of fuck boys like you.
- Jesus, you're insane!
- I'm not insane, I'm a doctor.
- Nah, don't you see?
You've become
everything you hate.
- What?
- You been blaming fuck
boys for your problems
when the truth has been
right under your
nose the whole time.
You're wife's just a ho, and
you can't blame the player
if you don't play the game.
(chuckle)
- My God, you're right!
How could I have been so blind?
Perhaps I was wrong
about you two.
You are not fuck boys.
- Yeah, we're fuck men.
- No!
Don't you see?
The real problem here
is that we're all
too obsessed with labels.
Doctor, fuck boy, skanky ass ho.
It's all the same, just labels.
Buying into labels and hiding
behind titles as an identity
only gives more power to
those who wish to divide us.
I think what we
really need to do here
is focus on the one
label that unites us.
People.
We're all just people.
(sniffs)
- That was beautiful.
You two should go,
spread your message.
Be the change that
you want to see!
♪ Be the change that
♪ Be the change
♪ Living's not
bad for you and me
♪ Be the change
(bleep)
- God dammit.